nobody saw those movies right because
nobody says honey let's look through the
tv guide thingy and see if there's any
wonderful things about racism or any
things about diversity i i really yeah
you know what i like at the end of the
day there's a really great
diversity humor
right there isn't any
so what do you do in there still i mean
if you if you feel this about l.a i ask
this to all of my la friends which is
why i'm asking you i mean most have left
already but do you what's going to come
of this place
well it's dead
i mean for example i started looking in
new york
many years ago 40 years ago they started
putting up the
the uh i saw it first in chicago they
started putting up the nicknames of the
streets on the street signs
i grew up in chicago state street state
street all of a sudden it's state street
that great street
go to new york broadway broadway
broadway the great white way well when
they start putting up the nicknames on
the street sun what you're saying is
guess what used to be here
right something that it ain't
something that's not there anymore so in
martha's vineyard and cape cod
and nantucket when i was a kid i had
friends in the east who were
their parents were professionals they
were doctors lawyers indian chiefs blah
blah blah and they had a place that they
rented on those
outliers right and they start i started
making a little bit money in my 20s and
my friends said why don't you buy a
place over there you know on the ocean
there's nothing between you and portugal
it's going for nothing so say yeah no
yeah no yeah no so now those places are
selling for 50 and 100 million dollars
but you're not going to find
anybody who makes harpoons
on martha's vineyard which used to be a
whaling
port it's gone right so that
that soho and and chelsea used to live
was where the ship's chandlers live when
the new york was originally one of the
great seaports of the world
right and when i was a kid working there
it was it was the capital of the world
but but you can't be the cultural
capital of the world without artists
right and the reason that the cities
existed
was
you took disparate elements which would
never ever meet in life for example uh
in chicago's woman who wrote a book
about 20 years ago called terrible
honesty about harlem in the 20s she said
you have these three groups that are
completely scorned and they have their
own wonderful cultures black america gay
america and jewish america right but
they all met in harlem and they met on
broadway and they cross-pollinated each
other it was incredible energy but now
we're completely separate in the city i
mean i say i go into my neighborhood
restaurant and
of santa monica i said that the
definition of diversity someone has 10.1
body fat
yeah i mean they they destroyed santa
monica
the promenade the whole thing they
destroyed it
yeah no it's uh you know you know the
diversity is somebody who hasn't had
botox
so there's no cross-pollination
cross-pollination anymore and what
happened to free speech
is the democrats and republicans don't
even speak to each other anymore
those who used to meet at the synagogue
at the church
right at their kids baseball game
uh i got a friend
she's a she's a black woman and a white
guy across the street rather than a
baseball game and she was talking to her
kids or black kids about something
rather and he said excuse me you
shouldn't white guy says to her excuse
me you shouldn't talk to your kids that
way about racism
that's it
she's saying to their kids racist there
isn't he said racism is all gone get out
there and play big deal
that's white woke 101 right there
so so so what do you think hollywood
can produce i mean do you see anything
sort of new and inspirational coming out
of that machine we're shooting we're
taping this right now just a couple days
after the oscars which i realized that i
didn't even know the oscars were on of
course i found out because of the slap
heard round the world but then when i
went through the best movie list and i
went through a bunch of the other lists
i did it live on the show i think i had
seen one of the films you know i flipped
through netflix and hulu and it's very
hard to find something that feels new or
original or or inspirational that the
machinery because of the reasons you're
talking about the hollywood machinery
seems unable to give us or maybe can
occasionally choke out something new and
fresh but there just doesn't seem to be
anything
left well there isn't i mean nobody saw
those movies right because nobody says
honey let's look through the tv guide
thingy and see if there's any wonderful
things about racism or anything about
diversity i i really yeah you know what
i like at the end of the day there's a
really great
diversity humor
right there isn't that i like to be
lectured by uh late night comedians
about how i'm racist right before i go
to bed that's my thing
yeah me too
it's it's terrific so the question is
who's walking i see when you got a
theater you know who's watching because
if they go to sleep or they leave in the
middle of the first act you better
change your mind pretty quick
but
when you own the high ground there's no
connection with the audience they say oh
you know what
if you want to see the weather channel
you're going to have to buy this whole
package and we'll sell you whatever crap
we want
so yet again
uh it's not that the inmates have taken
over the asylum but that they've been
kicked out of
the direction of the asylum because
because the the the inmates of the
asylum were the artists
right when you kick the artist out say i
get it
i know what how to use the theater i
know how to use film i'll tell people
what life is like
that black people are people too
everyone's people to accept the jews and
that sick people are sick and what they
they deserve are
you know there used to be all these
plays in new york but sick people people
were blind people who were deaf blah
blah blah they always won the pulitzer
prize you know for telling us
that the bad guy doesn't the bad guy
realize that a blind person is a person
too
so you come in humming the play
but nobody likes that play except the
pulitzer prize committee
what about sort of the disney vacation
of the theater that you know in the
heyday of the theater it was all it's
everything you're talking about it was
these incredible independent writers and
playwrights who could come up with
original stories and now basically
everything is a redux of a disney movie
either from 50 years ago or sometimes
from three months ago
yeah well when i was a kid
uh in new york the theater district
was
a slum it was dangerous
it was sex trafficking and confidence
men and
mugging and massage parlors and [ __ ]
houses and pool halls where you can buy
anything in the world
and great theater
but as the
the
the theater brought people to look at
the the cause of decay is always growth
right
when the growth stops at some point is
always has to stop
decay takes takes over to as you know as
the yogis would say to repurpose it for
the next thing
okay so the the theater district
especially from 42nd street is all when
when the middle class left new york the
theater still existed
but the middle class couldn't afford to
live there so the theater because it was
a money maker
appealed to tourists
that's who goes to the theaters all
tourists
so you can't appeal to the tourists with
a new play by a new guy
nobody ever heard of on a subject that
you can't reduce to a tagline
no one's going to do that because you
don't cost whatever costs 5 million
bucks the stage at play
so because
so the artists aren't coming to new york
to who wants to go do that play
you know
anybody can write that play
and i was looking it was a really they
used to have ads on tv or we should
watch tv years ago they said
not actors real life people right the
people in this commercial are not actors
they are real life people
i realized if you turn it around what
you say is yeah i get it it looked good
to me oh you don't need to be an actor
right
so you don't need to be an actor if
there's no scripts
because anybody can say you know i'm
kind of like i don't know i kind of like
little look around and i kind of say you
know anybody can do that anybody can
write that garbage
where the artists gonna grow they aren't
going to grow in the in the cities
they can't afford to live there
right and no one's going to put on their
stuff so something else will happen if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell